we can talk about your personal life
what's going on can i help you in any
way i'd be a good wingman don't you
think yeah yeah would i be a good
wingman
yeah
no okay no okay no you know what no he's
really good about talking people up but
i don't think luke needs that luke
doesn't need it he might be one of those
wingmen that you kind of steal the
thunder there's the he's the wingman
that actually you see him like riding
off into the sunset with the girl yeah
hey what can i say i was just trying to
help
who knew that she was
into a guy who's got so many good
choices as shocked as you are
why are we becoming vinnie barbarino
[Laughter]
was just trying to build you up
a boring son of a [ __ ]
yeah i'd be building you up by saying oh
yeah you'd love luke he was really good
on my podcast
what happened suddenly she's kissing me
who knew this had happened
uh i just think you know i i think uh
you should take me out some time and
because i see us having a great time
going on well let's do it let's go to
dinner all right but tell me what's
going to happen at this dinner seriously
i want you to look into the future
you're a smart guy creative what do you
really think is going to happen when you
and i go to dinner first of all what
kind of food are we going to do we're at
chasen's we're having the chili wait
chasing jason's closed in 1988
okay
we're at uh musso and frank okay again
most of them frank
they're still open yeah yeah
everything's going good i mean i i am
excited to talk to you i mean it's
really nice to be here and uh to meet
your crew and to see this build this
wonderful fortress we built this
wonderful place
uh kind of um a madman's lair if you
will you know the way um batman villains
always have like a kooky warehouse
that's shot at an angle it's got giant
question marks on the wall and that's
where his the you know the riddler's
gang hangs out this is my version of
that it is great to have an office and i
mean speaking of you know kind of
legends that passed away that guy bob
rayfield sent the direction yeah
terrific always read about uh that
company bbs
um that made you know last picture show
an easy rider and they do five easy
pieces five easy pieces yeah it's their
big one but they had a kind of a famous
office and clubhouse it was right kind
of in this neighborhood on highland i
think that was always kind of legendary
to read about but yeah it's great to
have an office like this i think what
i'd like to do
is
have the word get out that some you know
some really wild stuff is happening here
yeah in this building where we're making
the podcast you know i mean it's fun
during the day but you really want to be
there late night yeah you want to be
there late at night when conan really
lets his freak flag a fly there should
just be one morning where foam is just
coming out all the windows yeah yeah a
blue phone yeah a blue foam is coming
out the window and people and when
people ask say you don't want to know
you don't want to know you have to ask
yeah but i'd like to be known as a guy
who's like the center like this is my
playboy mansion can you start spreading
that rumor for us yeah yeah i'll do that
when i leave here yeah just say there's
all kinds of stuff going on don't get
too specific the less specific you are
the more interesting it's going to make
it see it it's wild i i know there was
it was the first podcast i you know it's
first one i did where there was an
intimacy coordinator
i was like
okay i thought this was a podcast
and how weird was it that that conan was
the intimacy
i was both the guy doing the scene with
you and the intimacy coordinator the guy
okay luke i'm gonna put my hand here
how's that